Next step, we're beaming into the future
with today's Food News.
Ooh!
(mimics eating sound)
(audience applause)
Okay.
All right.
Ross.
I know.
Tell me all about this.
Okay, well, hold onto your hat, all right,
'cause Mashed reports there's a brand new spoon
that's supposed to make food taste better.
What?
Yeah. This spoon is called the Smart Spoon.
It's $29 and it claims its sensory technology
will excite your taste buds
like they've quote, "Never been stimulated before."
(Drew hollers)
Okay, so like this is a normal spoon.
This is the... expensive spoon
and they say it enhances the flavor
and it improves the aftertaste.
So do you wanna try it?
We have mac and cheese and-
Duh.
And ice cream here.
Let's try first with the regular spoon-
Oh, all right.
So we can compare, okay?
Okay. I'm gonna go in for my,
like, this is my favorite food on planet earth right here.
Macaroni and cheese.
Okay.
It's good. It's good.
Now let's try it with the enhancing spoon.
(audience laughing)
I mean, it tastes the same.
I mean it's not bad,
'cause I'm eating ice cream, so it's gonna be good, but-
Ross, take a real bite.
(audience laughing)
How dare you.
Can you get your lips into the spoon?
No. Uh-uh. Like it's too deep.
It is.
It's too deep, I can't get my mouth-
It's like, I'm like, (mimics gagging)
Mm, mm!
I feel like this is a depriv... like this is-
(audience applauding)
I don't like it.
I don't like it either.
I'm proud of them, but I don't like it.
I'm happy either way.
Just give me a vessel.
You know, I just need my hand.
(upbeat music)